what's up fool podcast were so fool
we're back we're back for the Westhoff
full podcast we have Rodrigo Torres here
man
hello Lisa Esparza taking notes our new
host our new hosts are you guests yes
and there were over ha I'm not taking
over
I'm not taking on the one in our song oh
man
what'd you do that weekend bro last
weekend I had a I had a spot on Friday
and a Thursday over there and I'm the
one show was in a Pomona and another one
was in Boyle Heights it's a little art
gallery so art gallery wall street over
there on our first tweet just say Soto
Street no this is before it's like
borderline Boyle Heights right there if
you'll be claiming Boyle hide their bow
Heights out full Boyle Heights has been
on on up on an upswing the last five
years dude I people be there I'm in the
east side okay so they know Hollywood
that'd be eight star ain't no Eastside
Hollywood ain't no East Side man who's
come in here ready get like new people
come in like hipster from other
neighborhood from other other parts of
the country they come over here bro they
get scared row there's no culture here
bro you ain't know the same fools bro
what could do they have that they said
there's no culture here a pretty hanging
over the scene white people over and
over
make friends are not why'd you get
coaching [ __ ] you don't have to
do a tile amber you know it's [ __ ]
tight town you can buy exotic stuff
right there bro Bree could be an Italian
town which is only like three blocks all
Thai stuff you could walk into one of
those markets grab stuff take it back to
wherever whatever state you come from
and lie and say with the Thailand and
the way get a massage all of that dude
maybe one of my son but just take the
stuff from the store bro like stuff all
[ __ ] they have [ __ ] KitKat made or
[ __ ] them green tea yeah um confusing
Tokyo little tokyo really from the other
no tokyo smaller I think you know about
the same really it's a more blocks if
they're rocks if from first
Reid to Alameda first three to third and
him back right there whenever Skid Row
what's up Larry Omaha oh man I can't
believe it
what believe it's been too long bro with
the airport bro we saw your ad for
Verizon yeah you should have brought
that poster and gave it to me man I'd
take it real tight no but I believe that
we know that guy know it oh yeah yeah
there's somebody else call me go look in
the man look in the episode of
Businessweek magazine you got the full
page Larry no the full page I don't mess
around
yeah so you still used to go for dishes
yeah I'm still auditioning I had for
auditions last week for did four
disappointments last week so you are you
said you submit yourself
ain't no I got agent who submits me just
a major I've had him for about seven
eight nine years yeah it's a long time
wrong I know it's a decade yeah addition
for I'm auditioning for that show on
Netflix talk about which one no no some
addition for sure never late but you can
say you're gonna be on gente five
identify five man this fall this fall on
Netflix we don't know exactly date yet
yeah I play a guy named crazy Dave that
said in Boyle Heights - yes that at
Boyle Heights typecast again yeah I got
excited bro when I see when I see of
Mexican Americans are on TV or in the
movies like I'll talk about Mexican
American I'm not talking on somebody who
came from Mexico and he rose he from
Mexico and like an active of Mexico who
got a row in America to play a Mexican
okay nice I don't get he's excited for
him bro because he still lives in Mexico
accent he's [ __ ] Mexican or open as
well and guy played a Mexican guy I
don't care he's a good actor so guys you
know from Peru where were they from
Spain or for [ __ ] New Zealand some of
them played good Mexicans bro but I get
I don't get excited when I see them I
get excited that it's damn because I
know him from another movie but it was a
real mexican-american braga super
excited oh yeah I feel like I'm in
Liberal or even if though they should
no everything rosy abroad later [ __ ]
what's up fool everywhere but we stole
the show without him bro
coming in like a ninja what color the
name was Sue was real toys here everyone
very Coco coves of the week at least as
far as any robot we might Eric Weaver I
don't we haven't have we met officially
that happens a lot with me I'm went on
shows with the young guys but I don't I
don't really get to know them that well
so I forget I know a man like a minute
before we did a show him and I did a
show together in DC for the back then it
was called even know what it was called
back then Lhasa Wow
and and then LULAC was another one right
Wow new hack and that was cold I was
gonna leave together or no no I think
they're all they're all separate they
don't get it look it's like a
scholarship organization I think right
isn't it uh that's funny Paul do you had
a joke he said man we got the National
cousin at Rasulullah to let you know
that you didn't get along the only time
they got together was to take down my
show and let you take down the poor
local dog yeah they said there was too
many people in one house that's why a
case law he said oh they got the only
time the National Council last night
Unni those now and Lou like that
together was they got together to take
down the AKP pause okay Pablo and uh sir
take down the poor local dog talk about
yeah yeah super Pepsi taco dog Taco Bell
dog and poor local chicken yeah get it
straight
yeah that was great but National Council
si dozen is this anymore I think I
really yeah trouble given no fun being
broke
well they'd rather have instead natural
customer laughing ah so they have all
Berto Ricans Chilean under the umbrella
supposed to be just like mixer I think
they also wanted to avoid the word no
they probably stopped because Martines
had stopped using memory he doesn't even
take it in he's I don't talk like daddy
yes you do you um you know you know Toby
hates right yeah he from Omaha well I
grew up Baptist RINO his family clearly
his family is so the most famous family
they know everybody never heard of them
oh my oh my grandfather you went to the
UH ski game winning season you know I
didn't know Toby until I moved out here
you brought him to the wild cows you
barn with Dorothea I think so yeah hey
Jackson McQueen a lot of others would
you start a Larry a life started in
Nebraska man my first my first time ever
getting on stage and open mic
Eddie grill at some bar oh boy it was
called I was some Irish bar and as soon
as they introduced me a fight broke out
in the audience and I was so naive and
stupid I'm on stage telling jokes
thinking my jokes were gonna stop the
fight I was gonna bring the piece with
the humor really but yeah I worked maybe
once a week for a year in Nebraska and I
go okay I'm ready for Hollywood legend
89 teenage Wow June 22nd 1980 we'll hear
first spot alley cabaret or my first
night doing comedy now it was a comedy
store and I was so naive I signed up at
6:00 p.m. and they said okay you're
going on about third I go great well I
didn't know what third meant in comedy
store language I meant 1 a.m. so I go up
about 1:00 or 1:30 a.m. and there's only
about two or three drunks left and of
course you know you get no laughs and I
walk out of there depressed I was so
depressed I didn't go onstage
two or three weeks afterwards man and
then the next time I went up was some
little room in the valley got big laughs
I go up I am funny
let's go so um yeah I got me back on
track my my first time one of the open
mics have did was at 1:30 in the morning
at The Comedy Store
ya know I was up there just chillin you
know doing my jokes to a little crowd
there was like eight not 17 people but
they were not sitting together there but
it was like a single mass club again
scattered everybody I was doing homework
for after school and the next day a
number being bombed out at him and [ __ ]
this you know right but I just say [ __ ]
the Communists don't you say [ __ ] this
you know he goes I need a sign or
something you know
the next day bro [ __ ] no switch
earthquake bro rock the [ __ ] out of the
valley
so it was 94 84 yeah all that first time
yeah that was your sign I never heard
that story well I don't know I don't
know I don't know doing comedy that long
you know that mean 94 to to light that I
think I was CSUN right I was like how's
the nursery door wasn't open my Kurt
said it was right one Philip was about
one yeah
and I put up I remember putting the list
Chuy was there it wasn't the [ __ ] here
now they have the the big pickle jar you
put your name in there yeah right
I was stupid back there man I mean we
all were a million I wish it was smaller
like if I would have known there like
like potluck people I would have signed
my name 10 times bro
and put it in there yeah yeah over some
common we'll do that but there's one car
make I forgot a name he put his name and
in [ __ ] ink came up at 14 our
midnight and then they came up again for
what dude he did do two different that
universe he was the first guy from
Apollo to get bad because now well you
get bad for doing auto-ship but this
caddy daddy
he went double you know well I all I
remember about that first year here in
LA 1980 I was working day job at
Sportsman's Lodge you know Sportsman's
Lodge a big giant hotel in the valley I
was their house painter
and I would go to work every morning to
6:00 a.m. so tired from being out doing
open mics all night that I'd be so tired
I would look for a place to sleep
somewhere in the hotel but first I would
tape up wet paint signs all around
certain areas so they thought I'd been
working all morning then I go to sleep
abdomen you have to figure out you know
how to work the system put all paint on
your face make it look like you were
busy so I did that for like two years
where's Picasso he's sleeping he's
taking a nap man this guy works hard but
nothing painted but we never see him but
he's all done you got paint all over the
clothes my first year man just then just
hustling hustling it was covered in
light back then like there's more rooms
that they are now or they're not a bit
more refined or hard to find
there were like probably eight good
rooms back then the final just what's
your fire mentality weekly or yeah or
the mouths word of mouth and LA Weekly
we all knew where they were all up and
down Hollywood Boulevard and Sunset
Boulevard and then you know you had the
main ones improv comedy store laughs
stop at that time in the valley
those are laughs top of the valley it
was called a laugh stop in the weather
became the LA cabaret was true was that
about Bora Bora yeah yeah and now was
dining my place I know two rooms man
yeah the the lounge and the main room
man it was a fantastic room from the
time I came to town in 80 until they got
resold it got sold to somebody in about
88 it was sold out every night six
nights a week and 88 from 80 to 88 Wow
so no stuff left up there I'm just
called the laughs hot hot hot comedy was
hold out huh if I remember like looking
at the photos and your photos they're
like what the Drake issue or talks oh
happy those people that didn't like I
didn't mean him later but they don't
like it was like they had a time ahead
of it at this moment you know where
everything was hot and you're having a
lot of fun you know it was it was a
blast I mean it was I was in heaven but
with a la Latino comedian author or just
your apologies you know it was appalled
and Danny [ __ ] daddy bought ah George
Lopez George came along about late 80s
so you got to see a lot of these guys
when they first know the guys like um oh
that was one guy that was funny but he
were like a player he was Montgomery
Monroe or something like that I don't
know that name I don't know that Clifton
Monroe I don't know oh you talking about
Andy Kaufman's thing no no Tony Tony
Clifton yeah there's a latino guy that
had a like like like just a basic name
right it wasn't a Latino name yeah back
when you guys Danny more I mentioned him
more time at Willie's house
Oh Jamie yeah he started later after you
right yeah he was very young and he was
more of uh he was good MC yeah
and he know how to work a crowd yeah it
was hyper yeah I'm really hyper and he's
so he's still around I see him on
Facebook doing but he doesn't do
stand-up anymore
I don't know what he does now but he's
still in the business I see it when I
went to another Ally cabaret and it was
like a new owner like three three older
later and I saw his face and I said I
want the guy from living color's there
his photo - we saw him at 2:00 a.m.
videos that Coke
Tommy Davidson yeah Tom he was always
there probably kid yeah he was really
young so I thought I saw Terry Davidson
in 1991 at a Narcotics Anonymous meeting
bro in Pacoima
it was a candlelight meeting bro and
whatever these are weird what mycotic
anonymous cuz it's a big round table and
everybody has a role little section but
they're all candles it like it only when
you attempt to talk you let your candle
mm-hmm oh and you blow it off and if
somebody out lights is what's
interesting interesting and then their
narcotics we're really creative the
keep the guy out of a fillet now heroin
with a no cattle that's boon huh
back in the day we'll put Pacoima have
Bloods and Cripps oh [ __ ] so you started
litter in 1989 what did you beat Joey
bed though I met him in 81 when he was
there was a little club called comedy et
Cie down in south central area et Cie
yeah a comedy et Cie comedy etc and back
when South Central was safe we just go
down there I used to go down there and
do rooms all the time it was safe safe
for me townhouse and that's why I met
Jerry little Club there I actually
replaced him because he was shooting a
section of evening of The Improv so he
had a cancel and so I took his place and
he showed up later and we became buddies
ever since then man been good buddies
ever since then was he the turbine
cowboy back then or is that after after
he became turbine cowboy by 1985-86
he started wearing the turban and had
the cards at urban cowboy I still call
it the turban cowboy and he doesn't wear
the turban anymore I don't need no
[ __ ] turban to be funny so him and I
have so many crazy experiences together
most of them we can't repeat so I'm you
are you were working a lot and painting
I was I quit painting in 83 because then
the comedy boom really started yeah like
rooms start opening up all over the
country like Phoenix at four rooms
Seattle has a nice is a nice Bob's
Daniel put up rules right Bob zany has
rooms all up and down the coast still
you told me what time when you and I
were on the way of somewhere that I'm
Bob zany got so so busy booking him
booking shows I had to hire out he
little bit about our studio and Valley
he had an office oh go there you're
making the phone call that did other
bookings he was a hustler man he's
always been a good businessman so he had
rooms all up and down the coast it was
beautiful doing these great rooms on the
coast getting paid decent money and
partying and
it was a wild time it was unlike I
didn't expect that and when I got into
comedy I thought I'm just gonna be
telling jokes then going home I didn't
realize it was partying involved yeah my
chicks hot and steamy or just hanging
out Danny's bad just going to Danny's
with the guys it's funny like when you
when you look at a young comment like
even if you're doing a show visalia or
anywhere you know I don't know like so
someone involved with the short side is
a man everybody goes after the club -
Danny's at 2:30 morning so go back to
your hotel take a nap go back take a
shower wear the same clothes wear the
same clothes they could go you were at
the show I won't let it tell me what
that bro like we're doing a show and
then like it was a bunch of chick that
we're gonna take me and these other
three comics to go party somewhere you
go hey what are you guys going he goes
let's go party with a jingle no man
don't go over there you go over there
you lose your powers he huh huh he knows
yes hey right here man we put people
know who you are you're like Superman
right here bro go over there bro you be
back to front you be it you're about to
be Jimmy Olsen yeah even to this day I
tell the young comics you got to learn
to thirty thirty rule they go what's
that well winch you have the most clout
the most power the most charisma within
30 minutes of getting offstage and
within thirty yards of the venue after
that the club is across the street from
the hotel you still got a chance to hook
up with a chick there was at the hotel
room yeah she's there at that flyer all
day can't even go to the show my little
star and Willie Barcena - Tommy T's
server oh no Tommy T's the one
roosterteeth roosterteeth a home owner
we didn't even get a spot and
determination nice to get emails for him
bro it was time with T and on start it
was roosterteeth further okay you know I
was hosting bro [ __ ] that I was hosting
I think in a spot but there's no how you
been everywhere what's something were
there bro and the the the man she likes
me everybody liked me for the waitress
like me I'm being cool
I don't even spoke broadly with drinking
dog
Bravo smoked his cigarettes bro like an
idiot broken like I was out there with a
waste a smoky signal Williams right
entertainer now chillin bro right
I did a car I got a car I wrote back
inside he brings me back up I know
everybody whoa he bring me back up
because he had to take a [ __ ] Oh number
two yeah so he's up on stage 30 minutes
then he called me up as a gentleman
bring back your host Felipe Esparza so
I'm up there bro every time when you're
up there like especially when you're
done when you're waiting for the next to
bring the next person up or he's not
there you really don't know what jokes
to tell because you don't know how I'm
gonna telling into you to get off the
stage
so you're like a warm-up act now that's
to be short so I'm doing like he'll do
one-liners and looking over let you get
into a long story pretty much not
getting laughs for a while I'm like wall
away I guess [ __ ] huh
Apollo Kramer when he put on Jerry
stifles : ur episode yeah so he goes
back and then everything's tucked in you
know for your buzz
so he everything's plugged in like it's
a seven leather jacket he goes back on
the managers pissed off sad not kill the
momentum of the show hell yeah dawg Dan
you want to crawl back by asking by
telling now bringing up this guy who
just turned 21 and it they took the
Keeler shots so you didn't know you
didn't hook up after - oh hell no I
can't no power
hell no bro yo started to go to the fat
cheater working the front desk all week
and she keep going how was the show it
was good you know I laughs he goes and
then like she will come here by
room bro huh so what a lot of people
yeah a lot of people now a weird and
[ __ ] so the last night I go in there was
a man I'm doing lounge email you know
how to fold yeah maybe the lounge room
and she [ __ ] chose rough be right
back in ten minutes
laundry room bro just doing my laundry
talking chili uh-huh no sex by the way
but yeah man
oh no hell no no sex but yeah man the
next day somebody popped our tires ah
was pissed about that show like our
tires yeah we all have crazy will you
think was a duty it was a hit on him
though I don't know bro my craziest
Willy stories wind up we're up north
somewhere doing a gig and she like he
does know it was somewhere around the
periphery of San Francisco and we're
starving and we're cruising into town
and we're starving I go let's stop and
get some food he goes I love Mexican
food
he wants me always have coffee have
mills dog still and I'm just saying
let's stop anywhere man my blood Sugar's
dropping them from I'm dying they hug
you please hug you but I'm hungry I get
grouchy so finally he me broom finally
he finds a Mexican restaurant and we go
in and we're the only ones there and the
owners waiting honesty was the whole
thing welcome to my restaurant and whoo
and each order huevos rancheros he
brings the huevos rancheros and sets
them down and Willy goes what's this and
the guy says whoever's on Cheetos Willie
says this is the will of our son Charles
well yes this is where was in chair no
I'm from Mexico this isn't levels on
shadows the owner says I'm from Mexico
and this is where we make well rancheros
no yeah I'm from Mitchell gun or I'm
from wanna hot or whatever Wow bro what
they're going back and forth I'm going
Willie I'm just wanna [ __ ] eat and the
owner picks up the plates of food and
throws them in the garbage it says get
out you're lying
I'm not lying one [ __ ] bit threw the
food in the garbage said get out and I
look at what I got you mother I'm hungry
we walk outside ago there's a subway
that's where we're eating and don't
argue with the owner that's what we had
Subway sandwich argued chilaquiles bro
you know it was well wasn't Janice good
he's used to having the egg here is the
egg over her over easy on top and it was
it was Graham Buddha I don't know how
they made him because I was so hungry
all I knew was it was food in front of
me and I wanted to eat it that's why why
did you start eating while they were
arguing I was too dumbfounded these two
crazy Mexicans arguing with each other
who's more macho yeah Jesus Christ I
couldn't believe it
that's not how my mom makes him bro this
fool like he's different we're like you
know he'll talk [ __ ] after we leave you
know but then that fool would just like
start mad dog and start complaining I
was like oh my god is this happening
were you with this at one time after um
it was after the Casa latina and he was
drunk and we were buzzed but we were
just like well he was drunk yeah but
he's so there was like three Mexican
dudes it straight from Mexico but you
know been here for a couple years and
look at the you know cut grass and stuff
he starts mad dogging them and asking
them if they know how to do karate
starts roundhouse you know and he came
in like within that far from their face
you know I dude so just grab her
burritos and went to go eat in the in
the parking lot he didn't even eat it's
like what are you trying to prove dude
yeah yeah there's a million Willy
stories million you end up good yeah
like a brother bro
she's my boyhood of makeup oh he brought
her to your house holy
any murder I wanted him to make himself
yeah man I'm making with Pato sauce bro
the only way to make sure that he lists
the boyle heights way so there were a
crazy man was allowed with a lot of
people at that restaurant just just no
waiter of monterey germany we were on
our way to some room in san carlos i I
don't know who owned who ran it but it
was San Carlos yeah that was used so God
20 years ago he used to go uh noodle in
comedy you met Jenny Jones I know Jenny
Jones I just watch it with her oh yeah
you heard Joe Penna prank we did a gig
up the 99 for what's-his-name the
Mexican guy up there who Leonard Leonard
yeah yeah that was like 1985 yeah so he
booked Jenny Jones in 85 yeah well she
had then like what's your a lot in what
way like a comedy like no she was she
hadn't been on Star Search yet oh no yet
yeah she didn't get hot - laughs - she
won star search
she was just hot physically then and
everybody was trying to write for her
and be friends with her and she only
liked to cute a few guys you know she we
did some gigs together and Jerry was
good friends with her and another guy
John carrefour used to be buddies with
her but she shot took the snap she was
smart because she didn't have a lot of
jokes though she had 15 minutes and she
made it into a career she got her own
talk show
she's living in Encino now living off
her Millions
she's happy but I haven't seen her for
30 years that's crazy man you how
starsurge did you get I never got one
star search man Willy with our liberal
you what'd he say with honor he got beat
by Jeff Brown okay I don't know if he
got on TV I would have seen I would have
remembered yeah it was uh when uh the
devil did Star Search and then he was on
there after the show hey I was on the
real one bro yeah but remember with Loni
love but it was not the Ed McMahon one
it's the other day you know the the
reboot okay man
they have the International Star Search
- with the carlos alazraqui and jerry
bed knob were on the finals Wow Jerry
one international Star Search carries
all the way from Canada yeah oh man it's
not a crazy a lot of crazy memories not
a lot of them just blurred and gone the
80s was kind of a blur
you said Willie you and Willie used to
have a sketch group yeah at the Comedy
Store you cha-cha Sandoval and Freddie
asparagus very asparagus from he was an
emperor others and Willie Barcena oh no
no no no it was one other dude right
there was a lot of us actually it was a
big group do sketches and we did yeah it
was like 1992 and Freddie and cha-cha
approached me and asked me if I want to
be involved in it and I go yeah I got it
you know I got to stay in town more so
yeah I'll be involved with that and then
Willie got jumped in and so we uh we had
some great sketches working out for
about a year but then egos took over and
me and Willie and a couple of the others
walked away started our own group and
then that was too much work man having a
group is too much [ __ ] work yeah
and so I go and you know what I'm just
doing stand-up man can't do this get
[ __ ] going on the road well he said that
uh yeah well do the sketch you then here
in which we will do a stand-up and
Mitchell get mad I don't remember Mitzi
getting mad because we both did stand-up
mom myself and Willie would both do
stand-up in between the sketches and it
always went good I don't know why she
would get mad but we had some great
shows at that the comedies both of them
of the sketch group I want to say loss
we are weighed like two or three names
lost abstract owes what was the other
stupid name but the elbows bro I can't
remember
yeah I don't remember man it's been so
long you guys ever reconnect and bring
the group back yeah imagine that train
wreck
they called me many times we would eat
pizza
Freddie asparagus fries burgers chased
him around a Comedy Store no Freddie
asparagus was one of the reasons we left
the group he wanted to do things a
certain way and we disagreed and so on
well he a trained actor he was a trained
actor he was he wasn't [ __ ] man he was
in colors he was in every way with him
he was in Havana he was in three amigos
play the bartender three amigos he had a
way to talk on TV and he had a look and
he had a very funny 15 minutes onstage
oh yeah yeah he had a very 2015 he
passed away oh yeah he died in the 90s
of I don't know what but he was he was a
big guy and we'll do something who knows
something to this day when I hear
somebody say there might be something I
always think I think of a spare I've
never seen him do it man but I heard it
was funny like he was a wrestler right
yes yes
the he they do it they do it somebody
would introduce I'm gonna introduce
bumpy no fear pool and then he'd come
walking in Freddie come walking in with
this little Colt out what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do pump it or what
are you gonna do on Saturday I'm gonna
do Sunday it crack a funny time a lot of
crazy [ __ ] happening you know that that
series they had on HBO for a couple of
seasons about The Comedy Store was very
realistic I'm watching it and boy I'm
man I feel like I'm there again yeah I'm
dying up here yeah I'm dying you know
that was good did you know that go
c'mere so what's that I didn't know him
then I just saw I just knew about it
well you're the during a strike or
whenever I came after the strike it was
it was over but I you killed
Payne yeah a little bit little nip I
don't know what they pay now but they're
paying very little then I'm gonna Larry
Omaha tonight bro we went to a while we
did a show together at UH at the improv
comedy I oh whoa what'd you do at the
Clarion you and that yeah we never drove
bro hey you'll hear hey lady I got a
hundred bucks tonight
happy bra batter room for two days here
when I walk into strands bro
at night I'm looking for Steamies when I
started there was like us to like I get
a lot of gigs available but there was
some you know some to like my but my
rent was not a lot it was 395 but um
yeah that was thank you man remember
like we were driving just drove bro in
two lights the company Iowa yeah I
remember another time I took martine and
benny minute to a gig in Palm Springs
that was nice gig nice room you know
everything was great great food you know
back then if they fed you man that was
bone how about I did a show yeah and
Mesquite Nevada yeah I did that as a
casino Casablanca yes it is and I drove
there and that's right okay gonna be in
Las Vegas little personal with it I
throw a little Vegas I said it'll be by
Vegas make it the journey yeah so bad
somebody told me you know they said I
will Pro you been like it yeah bro let
me tell you man they got the best covert
of shrim your hangover the strip never
he'll walk bro get ready
but Tina thousand of so we don't the
[ __ ] I did there bomb no you did the gig
- not bad bro they were like bad and I
did the show with an old comic that that
comic was Willie's feature that had a
show one time his person had lightning
and nothing was oh and that guy was head
lightning and Craig Robinson was Petrie
yeah okay yeah used to be a great gig
and used to pay great yeah and then some
Pat Wilson
Pat Wilson has paid us very well and
somebody stole it from her so another
book and he just stole from him pays
[ __ ] money now yeah man we don't have
Ebola yeah yeah Sao Paulo said funny
like you never met these people that
book these shows but uh you know you
know like Pat Wolfe says she will put
that show and she were booked it'll show
darling a book that China Lake oh man
that what they had the big earthquake
last weeks ago risk risk California I
forgot now we're away from nothing yeah
yeah you get there around and the whole
city is the Navy base that's it Wow
yeah you get there like there's like a
guard and let you in and then on the
outside once you drive like I'm to an
hour and a half in just a bunch of
houses I stood in the house where the
Macan live here I had a liver room with
a bedroom and I'm too bad a yard and I'm
like wow man let me go there was anemic
night and she was there at the next
house and I could smell the weed you
know like the fact that I was walking
over the [ __ ] drugs do enjoy the
police club take us both out loud
Annie wow I haven't seen her for decades
yeah bad all the good gay Oh far though
we used to do gigs up on top of the
mountains above San Bernardino - up
Arrowhead and Big Bear they used to have
great gigs up there everyone had a room
up yeah put you up in the Hilton and
treat you good oh the worst place good
at well you say you know what about
there my car well you know what one of
my worst memories is peyote's no that
was good memories crazy good memories
man mom one of my worst shows was of
like 1985
the guy from who who one of the guys
from Le cab races hey there's uh you
want to make 500 bucks tonight hell yeah
okay what would I kill go to da Dodger
Stadium at midnight what so I'm an idiot
and I'm hungry brothers no joke for
Tommy Lasorda I show up there
the movie edward james olmos his first
big movie that he's producing and I go
oh edward james olmos man i'm gonna meet
him
maybe I'll impress him with my skills
talent by oh brother like you have to
care at it so I go up to the director I
go so I'm the comedian they said you
need a comedian out here what's the deal
he goes yeah you see those 1,000 extras
sitting in the stands well when we're
done shooting a scene we want you to
entertain them I go what to be an extra
[Laughter]
so they don't shoot it's midnight
they've been in there all day angry
people - yeah and underpaid of course
and so uh but edward james olmos is the
star and the producers show so like all
[ __ ] i'm gonna impress him man
microphone no microphone microphone but
I stand on the dugout on the top of the
dugout and try to entertain a thousand
I'm dated I given I give them five or
six minutes of my best [ __ ] and no
laughs and then they go okay Larry
that's cool we're gonna shoot a scene
now and I'm thinking more good jokes
they break it okay Larry go back up I'm
up there no laughs again okay we're
gonna shoot another scene Larry stop so
I go out and I talk to the guys who know
what's going on I could think we've been
here all [ __ ] day Larry we're not
gonna laugh at your [ __ ] you they've
tried five other comedians you're lying
yeah no I'm not so I go back after the
third time I realized I'm bombing in
front of Edward James Olmos son of a
[ __ ] and so I go to the director and I
said you know what this ain't working
man you don't have to pay me I'm going
home he goes no no no no here's your
five hundred man you know we've tried
other comics it's okay no worry it's
okay so I take the five hundred on I go
and I just pray Edward has doesn't
remember me that's all I care about now
get this get this
fast-forward two years I'm doing this
show downtown LA at a theater I'm
killing man I get offstage I'm in the
lobby shaking hands and here comes
Edward G
was almost there and he comes right up
to me goes hey you're a funny dude and I
go Edward do you remember the first time
we met he goes no I go that's good
that was my worst night in comedy really
but I got paid for it so you know that
kind of ease the pain oh man the hardest
yeah the hardest thanks all the best
Gabe's though they pay the most are the
one that her the hoppers give me the big
hearty sure like I did a show man that
like yours but at tropicale yeah yeah
and like the music there's a music
festival right so I know they're paying
me well I go to suit fellas aren't Main
Street on Los Angeles Street and I buy a
tux you know that'd be like Elvis all
gold bronze bro let's check it's a bunch
of people man lost even more they're
headlining oh man a bunch of like
Millennials are there and a mixture of
old people you know the older people my
age people but a lot of people a lot of
sensitive people oh I love world people
right so I learned a lot of words that a
lot of triggering a lot of words brought
it I never heard of bro yeah gender
fluid gender fluid all that [ __ ] bro but
you know what my father sold of my check
the president's wanted to kill
themselves yeah good I mean they would
have killed himself and it was tough
because they kept cutting down the time
you didn't have the time before they had
bad run long 25 wrongdoing for he ended
up doing like four or five minutes right
so Wow because they cut it because they
were running late with other acts
remember right before I went up the
first time when I with the scavenge amp
people on the stage manager cuz he
started getting crazy with
yeah the stage manager was like rushing
then they almost got enough who they got
in a fight with their people yeah they
shot him offstage yeah he's just like
I'll do whatever I don't care how much
time whatever it was just a fun day but
it was but man but it was tough because
he did like a few jokes and then they're
like oh my god he made fun of fat people
yeah there's a white dude up blood
like a wild man put his nose only white
guy the only white person he's right in
the front man somebody frisk him all
right and it's a fat ass [ __ ] Latina
extra extra l oh yes terrible ex she
said you know he's over there making
front of a white guy the other guy will
you be still typical I thought it was a
safe space yeah we need to get ahold of
the guy who put it together three couple
for over and talk about this and I feel
bad for these people you know because
you grew up you know you know I you know
you're like under 30 years old you know
you have so much life to live leave me
alone when you get to my age you realize
it's not worth it battles to be fought
but then you go like tell em you know
whatever you know but you know but that
one top KEK bro oh yeah well you're the
only comedian on that bill and they
build him as the host but no [ __ ] heart
until after Chicano Batman had finished
and it was like the night was already
like there were three acts laughter joke
for every time you waited for Batman
okay Chicago Batman but there was a lot
of people that went to that went too
long not you kind of Batman but the
other bad before that guy was up there
like that guy max just I want to sit on
his face born in April that guy was
wearing like you're wearing like I don't
know Zach yeah today I got next to that
you're gonna bat mara hurry
I did a show once where it was real good
audience and I was doing real well all
of a sudden poncho Sanchez decides to
start tuning up his instruments during
my hat the percussionist yeah man I like
your music but
[ __ ] now during my act so they would
comedy music yeah it's just weird it
didn't feel like it was a comedian fit
in there and they should just dead
announcer ready ladies and gentlemen are
you guys ready for the comedy you gonna
mean right shut my car just like there's
wait for another band then this dude
comes up in here yeah it was kind of
stupid it was weird but the funniest
part of it was when they tried it like
cool and they didn't want his fools on
you stop and he's off the front just
started busting up because it was so
funny
no funny bro and like that I get is you
know they thought they were gonna get
him cuz usually don't get me right but
it was a good one everybody say my dear
maybe if it was somebody that was
inexperienced and do you have like any
chops or so yeah but it wasn't working
friends they were to go cry and then
everywhere my face was was somewhere
like they say there was you go they eat
is vegan restaurant so and they put it
up for with the winnable talk [ __ ] there
but then didn't even
tag me you know because they're first
they're [ __ ] and some of these people
like they're like they they were they
hanging around with people that they
never go out on a bench out in the world
you know did I pretty much like you know
like some hipsters they call them solve
all their progressive but they don't
have no Latino friends know now what
makes me friends all these hips the
white comics you know they're they put
up these shows but they never invite
Mexican comedian you know like we're not
in there
you know they never did never think to
add one you know it's not even there and
they're mine I don't think be on there I
don't think beyond their circle you know
I mean and that's the way these people
are yeah these Mexicans right here
that's where they are little see beyond
their circle they're never gonna reach
out and say oh you know what I really
love that movie blood and blood out
because to them is something low yeah
they feel like dancing they call that
the old-school Chicano you want to
separate themselves as new Chicanos
against the old Chicanos who they feel
are racist or womanizing or whatever you
know right
it's the things so a lot of these people
are raised by your generation of about
about that like that their female common
what's her name
so when I said that good joke about
triple G or xxx Oh Dina good joke right
yeah maybe she would have thought that a
rose similar to that Josie very famous
yeah although she got a lot of [ __ ] for
it especially girls like soldiers and
apologize
yeah would you apologize I do offend
anybody I don't think I've ever publicly
but yesterday when I made fun of Eskimos
they come up afterwards a load me I
don't never apologize for a joke and I
never will you believe the show that
with a headliner in the leg while it
will ease it where like you know it's
going bad you really warming up the car
what about the time he pulled the girl
up on stage and they thought the
audience thought he was going to
compliment her instead he criticized how
fat she was all that [ __ ] I remember
that [ __ ] no we were in anesthesia
somehow it showed that book while we're
girls you want to show the boobs or
whatever their ass bra was like late and
it was Ronnie we're gonna have a big
booty cocktail I want a girl and they
come up I stayed with the biggest
titties and this girl just was a girl
with big boobs run up on stage and then
he goes I heard everybody his bars dude
come on bro I said big teeth not big
face big eyes big shoulders big ankles
he steals time that she poured her
career on him and and they start doing
chicken wings at it yeah he had to be
escorted out of the premises a low rule
while Quixote's go let each other do
that the next week and then the guys the
manager said no no no no
with a bucket of money get out of here
it's how legends are born bro too many
stories then you were uh you were you
were you were Willie at the radio disc
jockey yup and Sacramento weed I was up
there we went up in 2004 and that was
that was going real good and we were
getting a lot of work and we were
getting good ratings and we were all
making good money but there was tough
getting up at 4:00 and the more you over
here for both of us we were together you
live in separate we rented a condo
I lived upstairs in the downstairs and I
would go down at quarter to 4:00 in the
morning say Willie time to get up we got
to go and sometimes he wouldn't wake up
so I'd have to throw shoes at him cuz if
you get too close and try to wake him up
he jumps up and starts throwing karate
kicks he's got the would he call that
PTSD from anybody push books so and I
told him look ma'am you can't party here
I'm not a party animal so you can't have
any parties while we're up and he did
pretty good on that I think the only
party one night the whole year we were
up there together and but yeah it was it
was it's too tough getting up at 4:00
yeah it was killing me and then having
to have all everything ready I was
producing the show so I had to have
everything ready had to have all our
topics in line and make sure everybody's
doing their job and it was fun but hard
she's it most of the work I did a lot of
the work he did he sat there drinking
coffee and making smartass remarks on
the radio that's it no no we had a guy
working the board I couldn't work that
[ __ ] board man
that's too many buttons too many buttons
but that was a good year I made a lot of
connections and it enabled me to you
know really push myself up higher up the
ladder so it was rough but it was
worthwhile for me when did you meet
Willie I met him 1991 at age at shout
baa in Covina that was in there shout
out I remember that's it and Jack Benson
used to book comedy there Jack
black dude and one night I'm on stage
doing my 45 minutes and I get off and
this little Mexican kid goes hey I want
to be a comedian my name is Willy I want
to be a comedian I won't be and and I go
yeah yeah yeah that's good that's good
get out of my way I gotta go to Steve
you me oh they worry bro I don't
remember the disco Willy back then
because he was just annoying it's funny
picture that fool like that and so after
about a half hour he comes back again
I'm talking with some friends and he
comes at hey hi my name is Willie I
wanna be a comedian man I want to do
what you do I go that's good yeah that's
good go find some open mics and and I
pushed it I got him away he got away
from me and then two or three weeks
later Freddie asparagus and cha-cha
calling me to do the gig to do the
sketches and who's where who's there
also Willie Barcena
so we met again and he goes hey remember
me I make sure at the shout I go yeah
yeah I remember you and so after we
talked about the sketch group with
Freddie and and what certain Willie said
you wanna go shoot some pool I go yeah
so we go next door shoot some pool and
he goes you want you for money and I'm
thinking about this poor guy so we shoot
pool I take all his money he's all
depressed he took my money bro well I
can play you know I can play I don't and
together I didn't even have my stick
with me man it's in my car now but no
that's how I met him so that's what I'm
in and then after that he kept saying I
want to be comedian I go okay here's
what you got to do you know and you know
he did it to his credit he did it and he
bugged me enough that eventually you
know he helped him with his jokes and
you know he was he became successful you
know and the only thing that
then back was his his his his problem a
harissa you know but he was a funny
[ __ ] man he said that when back
in the day you were the only one that
had 45 minutes out of all the Latinas
all around I worked a lot I was working
a lot yeah I had a solid 45 and I was
working all the time but you know that's
what I thought you're supposed to do is
work you know right every day and then
go out and work at night a lot of comics
I don't I don't think they do that
anymore they try to get friends on
social media and instead of writing
jokes and when did a Latino comedy start
becoming a thing early 90s oh no it was
uh boomer Cervantes started he was a DJ
and he start hosting nights at the Laugh
Factory he his nights at the Laugh
Factory really started things going for
the Latino comedians and then he came
out of the woodwork man like cockroaches
really that's you and all the other guys
Gael Gilbert and oh you know how I meant
Rudy Modi know how he calls me up it
goes he uh is this Larry you know yeah I
got your number from somebody else I
need a comedian to work with me at you
Cal State LA pay couple hundred dollars
and I go okay so I show up meet Rudy
Moreno for the first time he goes how
should we do this I go well you should
go up and do your 15 minutes and then
I'll close with 45 he goes no I think
you should go up first I go this guy
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about so I go okay he doesn't know what
he's doing but I'll go up and do my 45 I
gonna do my 45 there 45 before him yeah
oh my god don't bear trap
a little bear trap and instead of him
yeah oh my god what happened so I do my
45 I say okay now here's Rudy Medano he
goes up and he does I swear to god I'm
not exaggerating to knock-knock jokes
and then he goes thank you and good
night
that was it man he reversed hosts so he
told me later on he goes he told me
later on he goes you know I've been
doing comedy for about a year but I
don't think I've really been doing
comedy I don't know what I've been doing
and alexi chicks that's how I met him
that guy never did open mic or what
he never didn't know he I think what it
was was he had a band and he was a DJ so
he would maybe do jokes when he was
doing being a DJ maybe had somebody tell
me you should do comedy exactly and then
the crazy thing is I was supposed to get
a check from a third party and I never
got my check and I kept calling the guy
from my money and I told Rudy hey this
guy hasn't paid me what's going on he
goes home well I got paid I go I am it
so a year later I see the guy at the LA
fat la at the Laugh Factory and he comes
up to me and he apologizes he goes hey I
know I'm supposed to pay so much money
I'm gonna give you double because you
had a wait a year so he gave me double
what he's supposed to pay me and Rudy
found out I got double he got pissed off
so I got my money cuz I got double but I
had a wait a year to get my money two
minutes whoo he did to me wanted to
check per knock-knock joke that's my
Rudy story so what's your what's your
childhood what's your background what
made you want to get into comedy like
that's a stretch my childhood friends
always looked to me to make them laugh
but I never thought of myself as a comic
I would always do impressions of
Muhammad Ali and and Richard Pryor and
Bill Cosby but I never thought of myself
as a comic I was just being goofy and so
then I go to college by some miracle I
go to college
and I take a speech course and all my
speeches come up funny and so the
teacher says you know you're more
stand-up comic
public speaker so she planted the seed
so from that point on I go okay I'm
gonna become a comic so from from
college is when I decided I was gonna
become a comedian and I even went to law
school but I said I [ __ ] lost go man I
wouldn't be a comic how deep did you get
into law school I did my first year and
it was just too boring and just I go I
can't do this man I was writing jokes
about the professor now with everything
going on right now with everything going
on with him in the news do you still do
the Bill Cosby impression no I don't you
want some new [ __ ] it's right here
[ __ ] all right Oprah yeah I
wanna get a double - man so really never
did like open mic now that I'm aware of
whoa I didn't know that brown privilege
bro no he was deep as a DJ and he was
doing so I assume that's where he did
his jokes while he was DJing so way who
gave him the title of Godfather comedy I
don't know maybe give ourselves titles
here guys yeah I don't know where that
title came from he did win the the best
Latino comedian The Laugh Factory they
had a contest huh huh and it would be I
don't know who bought it though
corruption involved huh but I I don't
even know the prize work but I didn't
you got some money and then a Friday
spot that he couldn't do because he was
at the casino but no one ever another
one so he kept the title Ellen's
funniest yeah
and I wrote out you know the runner up
with wanna be a rail yeah what's a full
metal yo coming up I'm heading out to do
a cruise ship on Sunday find up to
Alaska do similar to an Alaska run on a
Norwegian Cruise Line
oh good a cruise ship back we did
every night I knew it we did Latino
Comedy Jam or gay locals together yeah
alright and are [ __ ] hilarious
I called Oscar after he does a killer 45
here with closest was bad tonight he
swings a bat yeah an imaginary bat yeah
so I'm gonna [ __ ] your show with him and
we're closing out the show and that was
his name
doing the bad at the end of the show and
this was an aside him with a big boost
you know who you get if you don't [ __ ]
you you know but oh [ __ ]
he's like he liked it with acoustic do
the tandem revolution yeah I did
stand-up revolution
oh we shot it the first the first season
yeah and and I'll give you know I gotta
give a game a lot of credit cuz Comedy
Central did not want me on that show but
if what you are but Gabe Gabe insisted
because I know those other people that
couldn't get on also like Joey cocoa and
then there was a
luenell yeah they did watch you why do
they like a comedy they didn't like they
didn't I don't they never gave specific
reasons why they didn't like me I think
it's good they wanted younger they want
a younger face is mad your sweater bro
yeah funny other face it buddy you know
the gun up buddy yeah but that's it
exactly
but I don't know when you were young
well you're gonna hear your twenties
people say give me a young comic there
was so many funny ones you know I know
there were a lot more younger funny
people who were coming up yeah there
were a lot of I don't know when I
started doing stand-up comedy for
somebody who's fought in their 20s I
know there was me
right but now men everybody you could
just no no you could pick a lot of
people to pick from the younger comics
back then were funny because we had we
did it the right way man we were going
out every night hitting open mics every
night hustling
I don't think it's I don't know if it's
like that anymore cuz you see so many
young comics today on stage you just you
know it's not funny
what's that Willie told me that a bro I
look comedy for Larry bro here he
charged me I had to charge him in
wasting wasting all my time you know
that bad like they caught me up how do
you get started and sometimes man like
either Lisa emails them back and but you
know man they're like you know now I
just have a man who literally so much
information I sent him a link where the
third comedy OC they don't want to learn
how to do comedy they want to know there
are a secret way to get or you're right
exactly it's impossible Brooks Natalie
took me like 20 years to get here and
it's gonna take you like a long time bro
like what do you I don't have the time
to ask him do you have a wife yeah okay
that that right there is gonna slow you
down do you have children
that's not slowly down too bro unless
you start it off without all that stuff
you're not never gonna know hanukkah's
have a have a why have a kid I never
Rivera he recently got married now he
has two kids but I would I would have
been tough to start off my family I have
a family I did you can't do the open
minds can't do the scene you can't hang
out that's that's most of you look oh
yeah you look like you're 20 how old are
you thank them we'll keep it there he's
fighting rose with much of Rizzo bro
he'll [ __ ] you Johnny Rocio bro oh man
so yeah meso right when you started off
you were single as hell yeah yeah I'm
single at that stuff was right out of
college and I just started doing the
Open Mic scenes in New York and it was
doing three four nights three four shows
at night and just running the scene
would you start off at New York and you
know the first couple there was like
bars and stuff like the park lounge I
did hamburger Harry's which was in Times
Square and I saw this lady Gladys she
used to run it she still she's still in
New York she's been around forever and
then started doing comedy clubs and you
know just going through the whole scene
yeah the tougher over there you need to
start off or there's more rooms I think
it was I think it's easy I hear the
stories you guys it's not like you
you're still
more like the New York scene where
there's a lot of clubs you went you did
the open mics and now I hear people who
are starting out here is like oh you get
up on say for 2-3 minutes which in New
York you do five seven I don't know how
you growing to three minute spurts no
matter calmly until the you're three
minutes till they make you pay regular
then you get a regular spot you do
fifteen yeah
and back then it was like The Improv
wasn't even the Improv of pain but a
little bit bro yeah
twenty bucks you have not changed the
price everything attention we've taken
taxes fit up for inflation well we had
what 10 Bob we had um just the other day
my even with him I've never worked with
him we shot a TV show together we did
one of those stand-up shows topical
bothers I think it was come coming to
come back you did comical body was about
this I did to those up your audition no
I didn't move your dishes for that I
wouldn't I follow lady [ __ ] like that
goes way back I was like 92 really those
are the kids here lay how did you but
they pull that off I don't know I don't
know he just showed up into town all of
a sudden he's producing two comedy shows
a couple comedy show I did um I did the
Fort Hood did his show in 96 Latino
Laughs festival I was about the best
time I like my first half life or to my
TV first time lost I don't know how to
fly bro I didn't know I can tell you how
I got to the airport who drove me who
hosted my show was hosted by Paul
Rodriguez Wow and the biggest show was
hosted by Cheech and greg Giraldo and
John Mendoza were - oh wow I was
starstruck like all these convicts but
only like new - over uh-huh like I knew
his great Giraldo but I didn't know him
know him but I knew Paul Rodriguez and
job and doors I knew from television so
huh I act like I knew him right you know
who was on my episode my name Jose
Jimenez deaf wanted him on the Jewish
guy yeah Jewish guy who did the Mexican
character those only line huh my name is
Jose well no he had a whole bit that
went with it you know
but it was all stupid I should think
that dude was Mexican do this but what
that's yeah I know and that nuts yeah
nobody's Italian he's a Jew back then
bro you can play Mexican but you just
can't be Mexican right so you really get
to charge Willy because he was like
calling all the time yeah he was at my
place all the time man you know and and
it was uh I didn't charge you that much
like 25 bucks an hour you know
and I was fixing his jokes I mean I I
helped him fix a lot of jokes and showed
him how to write him zipper in the back
yeah zipper in the back and you know it
was just a couple of years and then he
was on The Tonight Show
so I remember that one time you you
wrote down all my job for me Willie paid
you and remember yeah so I don't know
where it is but I had that [ __ ] folded
up ten times and they were right jokes
on the back of the thing because I met
Jerry been a better show and I will just
chilling and then like there was a bunch
of Flyers you know for sure then I've
been a bunch of other people right in
and more I was part of they add more
yeah I first started off with the comedy
comedy show you know people don't
understand that dog star Lou like now
everybody put the whole world in that
[ __ ] flyer bright like they put first
of all they add credits that nobody
there were no credits or people that
were never on like tonight's show that's
coming Stanley but don't nobody the last
comment standing on a show and the whole
world is on a broom yeah back then bro
it was only one dude on a jheri bed nub
and the rest I had a notepad right and
then like and then you'll see another
Flyers and wait till the Flyers they
show me is gay yeah he told me a setlist
and it said this was from a flyer from
another show for three years ago bro so
he says oh he uses the Flyers the back
page right though his joke
recycling Wow four years I'd say he has
a whole stack at home right now still
have la cabaret Flyers he goes I still
got plenty of writing material I got
lots of writing paper he's never bought
actual paper actual paper resourceful is
[ __ ]
I got to tell you another story about it
so one day he goes hey Larry you going
to the Comedy Store tonight I go nah
don't have a spot he goes I go are you
going to goes I don't have a spot but
I'm going down there I go well you're
just gonna go hang out he goes yeah I
got to do something so he said I'll pick
you up so he picked me up we go down the
comedy stores and I'm walking behind him
and he goes walks in walks into the
kitchen walks over to the where they
keep their equal boxes of equal it takes
two big handfuls equal puts him in his
pocket says okay we can go home now
he goes she doesn't pay me enough I got
a make up for it somehow
that's bastard Jeff here's somebody that
I don't know if you told her J Bennett
told me that uh they they were a movie
theaters and there was a comment you
guys know doing a porno oh I never was
there but had a [ __ ] Tyler Horne he
told me about Tyler Horne Oh gross I
would hate to see him in a porno
although I've done pornos I did a porno
your your decide yeah the waiting
cocktails right I know you were like ah
which bartender I owned a shop it wasn't
a bar
I owned a shop and the sheriff comes in
and talks to me cuz he wants to find out
who he wants information thinks I can
help him and I'm in my shop I own the
shower gift shop and then the second
line in the story line in the porno is
my friend my Indian friend gets his
picture taken and from that point on he
feels like the camera stole his much
cheese more and he can't make love
anymore I know and so feel and so uh
long story short by the end of the film
I'm doing a I'm in front of a campfire
and I'm doing a ceremony ceremony to
help bring back my friends my cheese
more and so they flash back between me
doing the ceremony and my friend making
love to his woman and my face and then
ass my face and
[Laughter]
hey buddy but the craziest thing is how
many phone calls I got from people
saying Larry me and my lady were in bed
last night watching this porno we're
getting all hot excited ready to go at
it but then your face shows up did you
put that in your real it's not in my
real but it should be this guy could act
look at this he brought some as much
cheese more back [ __ ] oh and that's one
of the best jokes in my set list man
talking about the porn another one
called comedy on the road I didn't do
that either
yeah I did the 196 and look what he did
another one you do Latino Comedy Jam
funny is funny funny it's fall that's
right I did funny is funny I forgot
about that guy besides Byron Allen his
shoulder will always pay me checks in
the air
yeah like when his short wonder CBS
somebody called after man they were
showing all the funniest funny and other
Latino laugh festival shows on CBS at
2:00 in the morning
oh no they were out for two or three for
a whole month and finally somebody
called AFTRA and me and gay bro we got
gave her first got a fat chick nothing
[ __ ] it get some money get one you know
they have a manager to call anybody and
my money but man later on I got a check
for $1,700 yeah I think I know for 700
or 500 and that's my mother'll I'll Bob
your truck right away though [ __ ] that
this money might not come again was that
the great thing about doing the comics
unleashed early is is it was after it
was Union yeah you got me you got good
money no and then later on not anymore
later on I heard it went way down even
Union even scale for Union went down
this girl starts to gather the guests
are raw is nothing now yeah you get paid
just as much as you do to do a sale
tonight so $1,000 about 15 I'm sure you
still get checks I get checks now for
like six cents 10 cents all the time he
says all the time
it's crazy though the cruise ship I've
been doing cruise ships for a while man
it's uh it's a good gig it's a good gig
for me I started off in a picture with a
bunch of Asian women they were looking
at the boat oh yeah
oh the Asians love me on the ships man
you know they all think I'm Asian so I
met her on ship she's been dating her
for how long a little castaway huh
five years long times I should say she
picked me up she she stalked me she got
me after a show with 34:30
yeah so I do those I do this and still
do a casino here and there and but
Gabriel to write every word Gabriel a
lot a few years ago go to Europe north
on Arabia went to Saudi Arabia was
really fast around like like three times
it would it was when you opened the
curtains and you see all the men on this
side and all the women on this side all
covered head-to-toe
no no jokes about them I'd do a joke
about Michael Jackson talking to God in
that pissed us that the prince comes
running backstage she goes Larry you you
cannot do the joke about Michael Jackson
talking to Garko why not he goes we do
not talk to God we do not know what God
sounds like I said okay I won't do the
joke anymore but if you wonder what he
sounds like he sounds like me that's
funny but don't do it on stage yes yeah
it's what I get ready to do nothing I
just quit doing that joke so though
there was no problem but you can't think
about yeah so I went on this date right
yeah you can't talk about dating right
like I was always changing the right
song so I'm right with his woman right
and his mom and I'm aunt are with me
annoying me the whole time but Saudi
Arabia was amazing because they dirty
clean yeah they didn't want you get too
raunchy but they understood everything
they understood the nuances and that was
all educated over there you know how
many Americans would understand comedy
and two languages and and then we did
Europe we did a lot of cities in Europe
Amsterdam when we insulted a weed out
there I ate some edibles yeah I'm not
into smoking the weed but it sounds
fascinating
they understood all the jokes they
laughed bigger than Americans do they
laugh louder than Americans do and it's
a great experience Iceland Finland I
heard a fairly low comedy there I love
all of us it was there twice and he put
himself out there yeah he burned himself
partying you gotta go there once a year
huh not twice a year huh
once a year and and they want you to
have a lot of new jokes when you go back
every member everything huh yeah what
was it like thought to be a physical I
know it's cool as [ __ ] yeah we were
there when it was cold we tried walking
around for we walked about two blocks
ago okay we've seen it let's go back to
the hotel
it was cold how cold was it Omaha too
cold man none of us were prepared for it
we just had jackets you know you didn't
have big leather jackets or any meat you
said jackets so um but you gotta go if
you haven't been you gotta go what did
you meet Jeff Garcia what up back at one
of the Laugh Factory Latino nights so a
little jacket who's wearing a jacket
said what did say up with the bad luck
with the bad boy if we need to have a
little jacket bro nice man
yeah we're studs bedazzles how old was
he bad boy he was 16 17 or 17 years old
how old was he when he stepped on the
dice man boot at The Comedy Store sorry
bro
but I mean he was so damn confident at
16 man and you know is what ridiculous
ridiculous confident huh I would lay 10
G's now I'm only 17 that
and I heard he used to make fun of dr.
dr. Kim yeah cuz he said I make more
money than you I must uneducated
commedia I make more money than you well
that was back in the day maybe he did
load you always like that yeah and now
he's weathered around the picture a load
a girl I saw a billboard with him he's
got a youtube show
yeah that's what I thought Bridgers him
I think he gets a special deal on that
okay fundraising was for somebody said
they told Bobby Lee that oh man so many
crazy
well that comedian named but they'd ever
joke about being in beer now Rose
something Raul Martinez Martinez yeah
tall yeah it was tall
you know I'm a knight what time he was
talking [ __ ] about Paul got something
[ __ ] about Paul
but he's always close to ya party I said
we're gonna help me and if Paul she was
in the show Roy that day well he worked
for Paul I don't know in what capacity I
don't mean either for a short while so
Paul tried to help him what about weed
huh I don't know what I don't know but
but and then Raul just disappeared you a
formula he was crazy
he's crazy and then all of a sudden he
just disappeared I don't know where he
is now
the Frankie caras kill Frankie went back
to New York yeah what a play cuz I saw
what's-her-name brought the show there
are Spanish show and she showed up the
girl they used to hang around with the
blonde Cuban woman for Francis friend
she [ __ ] cancer right Francis Franco
Franco Franco Franco yeah Katie DeFranco
something like that that one not that
one that's the world I can't hear the
word
dinner ends oh but that I know that when
you talking about she thought she I was
just to pull up with him in a beamer at
the Laugh Factory
yeah she look you Cuban lady Katie
Franco Jaime Franco yeah I haven't seen
her for a long time
remember that [ __ ] in the top 50 Latino
less people see that list now and they
get married bro they said they know bro
but I shouldn't be right there or they
see the new list and they they say that
this person should be on it and why
would they even have a list you never
had a list of top 50 Jewish comics ever
that's crazy
top 50 white regular white folks you
fight each other ace always making up a
list that [ __ ] just cause trouble man
Mercedes Mercedes John Mercedes yeah
there was another comedian though there
was editing that list too yeah do you
know was here telling her that out he
was working on that live - with heavy
beams and he was number 15 here number
15 morning night I was happy but also
pay only people at La Comics knew yeah
how do people that got deals what's the
name they don't succumbed they don't
have a churro harbor with
what's-his-name
he was on that with you without him it's
like really bro Joey Medina wasn't there
with partner Randy Lube is work with
Randy have known Randy forever you said
that Karos room right yeah yeah dredging
up all these memories I tried to forget
it was crazy the first time I saw you
guys together you and Willie I thought
you were his dad in
and I thought Phillippe it was Willy's
cousin that's what I seen why cuz
everybody have the black leather jackets
didn't mean everybody had like a little
earring do you like it was trippy yeah
when Anna's family got three for once he
had to bet the leather jacket and
another beret brought to the back and
then when they would get regressive
showed up or late with a leather jacket
or two baby bro and a hoodie bro I will
be winter breaking down the jacket bro
like he was like a like a [ __ ] army
sergeant bro right dawg
you gotta get rid of that hoodie but
[ __ ] wears a leather hood in a late dog
[ __ ] belt but we want about four were
you ready to tie it up dawg Cinderella
Terry just had the leather jacket just
on stage and it will he go that makes
fun of his jacket overall for that job
yeah small hoof and then he set that up
and then Gabriel kind of buzzed with
like four chicks all over him and he
said eight really worth it for this the
a bro be careful dog those chains don't
really like you bro
they're gonna take your jacket and make
four miniskirts
letting any shine with the chicks huh
what's your oh it's Larry oh ma
Larry Omaha Eric Eric Rivera comedy our
everyday yeah I'm gonna be in a Fort
Worth this weekend for people-watching
hey this hyenas oh yeah and then two
weeks after I'll be gonna play no hyenas
as well Playboy you don't hate us I've
never done hyenas many other bad no it's
um it's probably cuz I always go I
played coyotes so they won't put me yeah
remember that's your broom oh yeah so
those the people that we have Fred
Stoller here right oh man
yeah she's been on several times several
times just on Fred bro hey how you doing
Larry old school that fool on the show
he was telling about his experience that
laughs and the headliner because he
didn't know that though everybody the
manager and I last the last he'll and it
was staying the queen yes you did you
say that that I'm that condo I say in
the condo and they had a way to live in
there too or not when I was there but I
stayed at a place a condo in Houston
where one of the waitresses would come
from the club every night to hang out
and then she'd sleep on the sofa in the
condo and I go what's going on with this
woman what she was I said was her bro
well I didn't forget this so none of the
comics messed with her because she's
just too freaky when we get back to LA
all of us got letters from her telling
us a sad story ha she just had like
$2,000 her and her mom could get a place
to live so she was set myself yeah damn
waitresses can't trust him down here oh
you did yeah we had a show we had him
and Brian Keith I don't know Byron he's
a chef now really yeah
has a cooking show with his brother bro
yeah yeah we have a briquette data here
he was crazy with a good show Byron used
to come to my house and I'd work with
him on his comedy he go I can't pay you
till tomorrow cuz my disabilities are
coming til tomorrow
what's a disability I didn't know what
disability was because you don't know
what disability is that [ __ ] half the
comics in LA are on disability I go how
that work I didn't know anything about
that [ __ ] fake an injury fake an injury
yeah if that workman's comp yes ah fool
baby shows this Friday July the 26th I'm
gonna be in Tucson at Sawadee the desert
diamond casino Monday July 29 Spanish or
San Diego at the comedy palace kill in
Texas August 1st through the 3rd at
twice as funny comedy club anybody who
lives near Waco Texas this is your
chance to go see me at the comedy show
also Fort Hood
shut up to Fort Hood come to the show
man we need people man we got like 45
tickets though for Friday Naples Florida
August 9th to the 11th after her comedy
club with mr. captain Brian in the house
San Jose August 16 McAllen Texas August
23rd Lubbock Texas August 24th and
Philadelphia PA
August 30 and September 1st and helium's
comedy club fool I did you go what's up
August 13th via memos jokes and rumors
that Joe's doing that show life farts
building with Felipe Esparza Marc Rizzo
loose fossils no huh
but years ago at the ice house we did a
show I was hired to do a show in Spanish
I go I don't speak Spanish
think of what will pay you $1,000 if you
do I go how much time five minutes
old I live so I learned five minutes I
had two coaches and I go up I do my show
get big laughs and I go I got bigger
laughs in Spanish than I did in English
with those jokes they go they weren't
laughing at the jokes they were laughing
at your accent what's up Leo maja go get
it go go to a cruise ship ago I live
over ha yes if you're in Alaska just to
jump on the cruise ship I'll get John
give you your car back don't be hitting
them up he charges 75 relations
Omaha's finest before I remember looking
at Willie's jokes and it was all your
writing all the time yeah what did I
learn about him and really and you is
that um you gotta go over your set and
that we don't like doing that no more
yeah even a big car breaks they watch
this comic like corner goes oh man he
can't even do that or know people do
this well you gotta do it like did you
go I still I still listen to myself even
if I do an hour I still listen to it
like I hope I got a weed problem so I
gotta remember stuff you know it's my
job yeah he's to Gloria said sometimes
yeah I record them all on the phone I
got a hundred sets right here that I'm
right here core tomorrow man and a lot
of people don't do it I don't understand
how they grow how do you grow I know
Matt like I listen to my station table
[ __ ] up yeah is where lots of crowd
you turned on me with you woke fool
thank you very much thank you brother
they were all behind in your house
always nice to see you
steamy